[MUSIC PLAYING]
MELISSA POULOS: We have
Rakesh Satyal with us today,
really excited.
Award winning author and editor,
teaches at NYU, sings cabaret,
and you need to
check that show out.
It's great.
And very, very close
friend of mine.
So we are super thrilled
to have you here, Rakesh.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
RAKESH SATYAL: Thank
you for having me.
MELISSA POULOS: He has gotten
some incredible press lately
with the launch of
his second book,
"No One Can Pronounce My Name."
Am I pronouncing
your name correctly?
RAKESH SATYAL: You are,
yeah, after all these years,
you're now asking
me, after 15 years.
MELISSA POULOS:
It's been 20 years.
But welcome, and
welcome to Google.
And I thought maybe you could
do a quick intro for everyone,
tell us a little
bit about yourself,
that I haven't
already told them all.
RAKESH SATYAL: So, as Melissa
said, this is my second novel,
it just went on sale in May.
My first novel, "Blue
Boy" went on sale in 2009.
It shows you how lazy I am.
So I'll see you in eight years.
And I grew up in Ohio.
So both books actually
take place in Ohio.
The first one takes
place in Cincinnati,
which is my hometown.
And this latest one takes
place primarily in Cleveland.
And I've worked
in book publishing
for more than a dozen years.
I actually began my
publishing career as an intern
at what was then known at the
Doubleday Broadway Publishing
Group, which was
Park Random House.
And I worked for
a legendary editor
there, who's still there,
who was a wonderful mentor.
So I worked for him for--
after I graduated-- we actually
graduated from college,
and the following Monday,
I started working for him
as his assistant.
So that was very fortuitous
to intern for him.
And then I worked there for
about four and a half years,
and then I moved over
to Harper Collins,
where I worked for
another for five years.
And some of the bigger
authors I worked
with when I was at
Harper that I edited
were Paul Rudnick,
Paul Coelho, who
wrote "The Alchemist," Clive
Barker, Armistead Maupin who
wrote the "Tales of
the City" series, who
has a new memoir
coming out this fall.
And then I actually
had a detour,
closer to your world
of things, where
I worked at Lexicon Branding and
in Sausalito, California, doing
naming work.
So I worked there
for a while, and was
in the world of branding for
about three years, all told,
doing naming work.
Back here in New York, as well.
And then I went back into
publishing, which is a rarity.
People sometimes leave
and they don't go back.
But I really missed
working with authors.
I really love working on--
I love editing their work, I
love conceptualizing their work
with them.
So I work at Atria
Books, which is
a division of
Simon and Schuster,
where I primarily work
on narrative nonfiction.
And then I do some
literary fiction as well.
Some books that I'm
working on currently,
actually this past Tuesday, my
author Janet Mock's new memoir
went on sale, "Surpassing
Certainty," which is wonderful.
I have a memoir coming out this
fall by the TV writer Michael
Ausiello, who wrote a
really popular column
for "Entertainment
Weekly" for a long time,
called "Ask Ausiello."
I'm glad you know who he is.
And we actually just got an
amazing plug for that book
from JJ Abrams.
So that's very exciting.
And I'm doing Jake
Shears' memoir, who
was the lead singer of Scissor
Sisters, that band, which
goes on sale next spring.
That's going to be a ton of fun.
Then I have an Italian novel
that I'm really excited about,
next March, called "The Eight
Mountains" by a writer named
Paolo Cognetti, which is a short
novel, about 200 pages, about
the lifelong friendship
between two Italian boys who
meet in the Alps, one who's
from a family of privilege,
and one who comes from salt
of the earth, mountain family.
And it's sort of
like people comment,
it's sort of a male
Elena Ferrante.
It's that kind of storytelling.
It's really beautiful.
So that's kind of my
professional life.
And then, it's been really
exciting having this out.
And so, I wear both hats,
including this awful baseball
cap.
And so I do it all.
So that's some 500
things about me.
MELISSA POULOS:
Well, I want to talk
about the book in a second.
But I first wanted to ask
you a bit about your process.
So it's your second novel.
How do you work?
How is it different
maybe from the first one?
Tell us a little bit about
how you came to finish this.
RAKESH SATYAL: You know, I tell
all my authors all the time
when I'm working with them,
have a real, be very regimented,
have a schedule,
write every day.
I'm a complete hypocrite,
because I don't do any of that.
I feel like since I'm a
task master in that job,
I can just sort of
fudge it on my end.
It was very instructive
working on a second book.
I know you hear about
sophomore slumps,
and you hear about
going back to the well,
and how difficult it can be.
With the first book,
I think most people,
you feel an urgency to
kind of tell your story,
to get your voice
out into the world.
There's a certain
propulsion behind that,
to get your thoughts
you've had kicking around
in your head for quite some
time out and onto the page,
and then into people's hands.
And as with many
writers, my first book
was semi-autobiographical,
and I mean more of it
is conjured than
people might think.
But that had a certain
movement to it,
because I felt urgency about it.
I felt like I knew who
the characters were,
I knew the character.
It'd be written in first person.
It would be-- the
12-year-old Indian boy--
the first book, "Blue Boy"
is about-- it takes place
in a very fixed period
of time in the life
of a 12-year-old
Indian-American boy growing up
in the Midwest, who thinks he's
the reincarnation of Krishnaji,
the Hindu god.
So there's almost a
construct established
at the beginning
of that book, where
he goes through
certain exercises
to almost make his life
match the life of Krishnaji.
So there was almost
a roadmap I created
for myself to finish that book.
And it was just a question
of pushing myself to do it.
This book was very different.
Because I began
writing it not sure
if it was going to be
a short story or what
it was really going
to end up being.
And what happened is--
the central
relationship in the book
is-- there are two main
characters in the book.
One is a middle-aged
Indian man in his--
he's in his mid-40s, who lives
in Cleveland with his mother.
And you find at the
beginning of the book that--
I might read from
that later, so I'll
tell you what you
find out later--
but that's one of
the main characters.
And the other
character is a woman
in her mid-40's,
who has just seen
her first, her only child,
her son, off to college,
and is sort of
unhappily married.
And to keep herself enthused,
she writes paranormal romances
as a secret.
So it's about how the two
of them become friends.
But that made that first
character I mentioned,
he came from the idea
that years ago, I
had a family friend whose
uncle came to town to visit.
And if you know
Indian people, uncle
is a catch-all term
that can mean anything
from an actual uncle to some
tenuous familial connection
that you don't even like.
So i met a family friend of
his, who was in his mid-40s.
He was unmarried.
He lived with his
mother in New Jersey.
And I remember everybody having
this implicit understanding
about him, that because
all those things were true,
he had to be gay.
Because that was
the only reason that
could explain having that
kind of life, so to speak.
And I remember being
doubly disheartened
by that, because
one, I was obviously
a closeted teenager
in the Midwest
and found that kind of gossip
not particularly encouraging.
But also, in addition to that,
and an extension of that,
people were framing
his life for him.
There was no-- he had
no agency in the way
that people were
talking about him
and what his story might be.
So I started writing
that character.
I felt like because my first
book was a younger character,
there were certain queer
themes that were explored.
And I felt a responsibility
to kind of talk
to people at a different
point in their lives.
And be completely
frank, when I was
writing that
character initially,
I was incredibly lonely.
My life as a single,
not happily single,
and I was dealing with all
of these issues of like kind
of what it means to be
lonely, and if that's
your default state, if that
can be made productive at all.
And the more I began to write
that character-- actually,
when I initially
started writing him,
I didn't really think
about necessarily
what his sexuality
was going to be.
And then when I thought
about the themes
I was really trying
to capture and what
I was trying to do
with that character,
I realized actually it's
much more compelling
if he is in fact
queer in some way,
and he doesn't even know what
he thinks about the world.
So because of that-- and again,
laziness comes into play here.
Because there were
different threads,
there are those two
main characters,
and there are a lot of
auxiliary characters.
And the book is told in a
close third person among them.
I would get really lazy
writing one character,
not sure what was happening.
And then I would just
jump to the other one,
and start writing that.
And then I would
jump to the other one
and start writing that.
And then when you
go back, it really
makes your job much
harder, because if you
want to create a cohesive
narrative, as a writer,
it's not great to
do that to yourself.
Because you are like, oh, where
was I, and what does this mean.
And what was I
thinking a year ago,
when I was writing
that other section.
So all this to say, I made
it much harder for myself.
It was much harder.
But I certainly
learned things going
into the next project I work
on, of like how not to do that,
how to keep a better idea,
a work ethic in mind that
will keep me on track.
MELISSA POULOS: Well,
I think we should just
keep talking about
the book, because now
that we've introduced
one of the characters,
maybe tell us a little
bit more about some
of the other
characters plot lines,
and maybe we can
do a quick reading.
RAKESH SATYAL: So,
that's the main.
I'll read his section, so
you'll find out about him.
The second character,
Ranjana, like I said,
she lives in Cleveland
with her husband,
Mohan, and they've just seen
their only child, Prashant,
off to college.
He goes to Princeton,
shocker for us.
And she-- because she feels
very isolated-- and one
of the things I was
exploring in her character
in particular-- both
of them, both Harit,
who's the other
character, and Ranjana,
are people who haven't spent any
copious amount of time thinking
about, again, what agency
they have in the world,
like what are they allowed
to feel, what are they
allowed to talk about.
And in her case, she realizes
over the course of the book--
because she actually has
quite a relatively sharp sense
of humor, that it's not just
she's like incidentally funny
because she's an Indian
woman living in America,
and because she bumps up
against people she doesn't know.
But in fact, she
can she can take
what she knows about
the world and actually
employ it in a certain way,
in the way that she writes
about the world,
in the way that she
interacts with
people, that is closer
to her actual personality.
It's like her personality
is caught in her head,
but it's not in practice at all.
So that's really-
I was exploring
that with her character,
in terms of taking a really
feminist stance in
a way, of how would
she have come into
her own that way.
And then the third main
narrative in the book
is Prashant, her son, who
is a freshman in college.
And in his case, because
he's kind of checked off
all the boxes for
his family, he's
very studious, he's a chemistry
student, he's very sharp.
And he realizes
that because he's
been dutiful in a lot of
ways, and because even when
he's acted out, if he's like
smoked pot at some point,
or if he's gotten drunk,
like during high school
with his friends, that nothing
has really prepared him
for the social interactions
he's going to have romantically
in his life.
And so he develops a crush on
this kind of stereotypically
beautiful and but then
like kind of darkly
smart young woman in his
class, he has a crush on.
And he realizes he
doesn't know at all how
to engage with
anything romantic,
because his parents have
set no example for him.
So it's really
the three of them.
And then the other key
character is Harit's mother,
the first character I mentioned.
His mother is-- later in
life, and you find out
in a particular flashback scene
what the trajectory of her life
has been up to that point.
So it's really
looking at people who
are on the margins of
society and how they actually
insert themselves
into the conversation
willfully, as a result
of the things that
are happening around them,
and tons of gay stuff.
Tons of gay people.
MELISSA POULOS: That sounds
really funny, really beautiful,
really sweet, touching story.
It's incredible.
And you mentioned at the
end of the acknowledgment
how you credit
your husband, John,
how it started off
in a sad place,
and has now ended up in
a very hopeful one, which
I think was really lovely
at the end of the story.
And so many of the
themes in the book
are so timely, sort of this idea
of loneliness and belonging,
and sort of identity
and feeling displaced,
making unlikely
connections with people.
And obviously so many of us can
relate to that, particularly
as being immigrants
ourselves, or being
children of immigrants
in this country
and sort of how that feels.
So the characters
are incredible.
And I love how they all
sort of start off, it seems,
suppressing aspects of
who they really are.
And only through the
interactions and relationships
with each other, they build
on, and bring out really,
their own personalities by
playing off of on another.
RAKESH SATYAL: I love that--
thank you for saying that,
because really, that was the--
what I like to tell
people is when I first
started writing the
Harit character,
I was actually at a writing
residency in Provincetown,
that Colin McCann, the amazing
novelist, Colin McCann,
was running.
And one of the
exercises he gave us
in that class, which is
really instructive to anybody
who is writing--
and I'm not sure if
this was an exercise
that he created or it might have
been what he was passing along
to us--
and I happened to be
beginning to write
that character at the time.
This was in 2010, so
this gives you an idea
of how long ago this was.
And he said describe
the strangest person
your character has ever met.
And the challenge
of that is it's
not the strangest
person you've ever met,
it's the strangest person
your character has met.
So it gives you a
certain challenge
to see the world through
that person's eyes
and think about the
things that would
be challenging or
confounding in a lot of ways
and funny in a lot of ways.
And that was really
fortuitous to happen
at the beginning of
my writing process,
because I knew already the
book was going to be composed
of interactions like
that, that there
were going to be
people who bumped up
against each other who were of
completely different mindsets,
and that the comedy would result
from that misunderstanding.
So that was very conscious
on my part to do that,
and I'm glad that
you noticed that,
because that's a real crux of
the book as you go through.
MELISSA POULOS: So tell
us a little bit more
about kind of where the
origin of the story came from,
some of the characters
that we've heard about.
I mean, I know you've
got a lot that you
drew on from your own
experience, and your family,
and sort of your own
parents, who are from India,
and their kind of
romanticism about America.
And maybe how that had
changed over the years.
RAKESH SATYAL: Well,
at a certain point--
years ago, my thesis
adviser, actually,
when we were at Princeton,
was David Ebershoff,
who is a wonderful novelist,
who, among other things,
wrote the book that became,
"The Danish Girl," which
became that amazing movie.
And David gave me a
really amazing piece.
And he was a
publishing mentor too,
because he's a very
brilliant editor.
And he gave me a really
amazing pieces of advice
when I was his advisee, where
he said just tell the story.
Meaning, the way
I kind of explain
that now is that, if you've
been trained as a writer,
if you've been writing,
if you've been exercising
that muscle so to speak,
at a certain point,
you have to trust your
creative worldview,
and your general world view of
how you see things, and tell
the story that you
really are meant to tell
and that you're needing to tell.
In a sense that I
kind of synthesized
all these things
about what I learned
from writing my first book, what
I've learned from my own life,
what I've read and
learned from other people.
And kind of thought, you
know, I can't get held up
on checking off boxes
or trying to fill
what I think are sort
of conventional ideas
on what a novel should do
or what my fiction should
be doing, but really
focus on these characters
and see how I really
envision them.
And in a way, the
Harit character
had a real life
connection in that sense.
But like Ranjana and
Prashant, and other people,
they're really a synthesis
of all these other things
I brought in.
And I really just
sort of trusted
that to give me momentum
through the book.
I was saying this earlier at an
event I did in May here in New
York, and this is sort
of a shoddy metaphor,
but I kind of think
of the writer's brain
as being a crystal ball, and
you take a hammer, in a way,
and you just take it and
you shatter that ball,
and the shards go everywhere.
And that's your book, in a way.
Like all those
shards are characters
that have come from your mind.
And they all look
different, and they all
are different sizes
and shapes, and they
may reflect different things.
But that's kind of
the way it happens.
It is part of you.
And we say often that the more
dangerous thing than people's
assuming that the
main character is you,
is people assuming that every
character is you, so to speak.
And in a way, they are, because
they're coming from your mind.
But at a certain point you
have to trust your instincts
and your creative verve
to be able to fashion that
in a certain way, where it just
doesn't seem like you again
and again.
MELISSA POULOS: Should
we do a quick reading?
RAKESH SATYAL: Yeah, I'll
read from the very beginning.
So no spoiler alerts here.
Spoiler alert, you'll love it.
No, I'm joking.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm just going to read from
the very beginning of the book.
So here we go.
"Harit descended the rubber
coated-stairs of the bus
and tripped as he jumped
to the sidewalk below.
He turned around to see
if anyone had noticed,
but the bus was
already pulling away,
leaving a dispersing
cloud of smoke and people.
It was a short walk from
the bus stop to his house,
but within 10 paces
he began to sweat.
The heat seems so hot here
because the surroundings
didn't look as if
they could stand it
any more than the residents.
The thick roofs, many
shingled and arched,
the roads bracketed
in deep curbs,
and the trees, branches bursting
and then shivering in leaves,
were all suited to
a cold landscape.
Harit had seen this theory
proven during his first winter
in Cleveland, when snow piled
on top of those shingles,
nestled into those curbs, and
spackled the leaves in ice.
But in the summer,
the neighborhood
seemed like a tired old man who
could not endure such exertion.
The house in which Harit lived
stood opposite a large baseball
field.
The field was surrounded
by a sextet of light posts
so large that they
could have constituted
a new seven wonders of the world
had another counter-part been
shoved into the ground.
It seemed that a different group
of boys appeared on the field
every night, clad
in uniforms of red,
yellow, and gray polyester,
or during practice games,
and assortment of
sweats and mesh.
Their hollers would last until
9 PM, when the lights shut off
with an ear-splitting pucker.
The fields diamond was
on the opposite side
of where the bus stopped
and Harit's house stood.
So he didn't have to interact
with the kids very often.
But there were those
afternoons when
a ball would find its way to
Harit's side of the field,
and some fragile little kid
would run over to get the ball
and look terrified
that Harit was going
to do something awful to him.
There was that quick shake
of the head, a short no,
and Harit, who
should have learned
to look in front of himself
and not at others by now,
would move away.
Today, thankfully, he had
an uneventful walk home,
and when he slid his key into
the back door of his house,
he had one second of peace.
But as soon as he
turned that key,
it was time to get into costume.
He wasn't sure why he put
the rose oil on anymore.
It had seeped into
his skin by now.
Teddy had already
sniffed him and asked him
why he had started to smell
like someone named the Dowager
Countess, who Harit
didn't know, but who
according to the
tinny voice that Teddy
used to say her name, sounded
like a very small woman.
Harit cursed himself and he
remembered that he had run out
of lipstick yesterday.
Luckily, he had a bit of
raspberry Chapstick left,
and a few heavy circles
around his mouth
pretty much did the trick.
The sari that he'd been
using for the past week
was beautiful, a peacock blue.
But he had started
to smell in its folds
a stale version of his
own pungent body odor.
He took the bottle of rose
oil against his index finger,
and trying not to
stain the fabric,
flicked small droplets onto it.
He then whipped the sari
into the air the way
he did with his
blanket when making up
his bed in the morning.
He sniffed the sari again.
There was still the
unmistakable sourness,
but the rose oil now
clouded it enough
that his mother's old nostrils
would not detect the smell.
She was in her armchair
in the living room
and the stereo was going.
Gital Didi had brought a new
batch of cassettes for her,
and the latest one
was a Mohammad Rafi
Best Of collection.
That voice, normally
lively, was so muffled
by the old stereo
speakers, that it
sounded as if poor
Muhammad himself were
trapped inside the machine.
Harit, for all the
sadness of the situation,
had to stifle a
laugh as he looked
at his mother, the sentinel
of a caged mega-star singer.
She had taken to wearing
a pair of" eyeglasses--
sorry, purple-- "gigantic,
purple-rimmed sunglasses,
also a gift from Gital Didi--
which made Harit's job
both easier and harder.
Easier because they filtered out
such mistakes as his Chapstick
lips, harder because they
made his mother even more
inhuman and unapproachable.
Her eyes, even under the
gossamer of burgeoning
cataracts, were a pair of
darting, glimmering circles,
that were abnormally
large for her face,
and that have often made
people mistake her for a South
Indian instead of a Punjabi.
But now, with her
new eyewear, she'd
become a wax figure
of herself, an effigy
upon which some child
had played a prank.
Still, something in her
defied total weakness.
The way that her mottled
hands rested on the chairs arm
rests, the way that her
white sari, though jaundiced
with time and over use, flowed
like the raiment of Saraswati.
The way that her hair,
ghastly white, held its bun,
save for a few to defiant wisps.
It all emphasized her
determination to mourn forever.
Is that you, his
mother asked in Hindi.
It was always the first
thing that she said.
She didn't speak
English anymore.
And she used the informal
you in a childlike manner.
Harit gave his usual response.
Yes, Mother, it is Swati."
I'll stop there.
So what that
establishes is that--
what's happening
in that scene is
that you find out that
Harit's sister, Swati,
who was his confidant,
and really only friend,
has passed away, in a
circumstance that you
find out later in the book.
And so his mother, whose
eyesight is dimming,
he thinks to kind of
keep them both sane,
he will dress up in
her saris every night.
So that's how the book begins.
And that introduces
his character.
MELISSA POULOS: It's great.
It's really captivating.
Because the description
is incredible.
And then you're always
thinking what is going on.
RAKESH SATYAL: It gets
funnier, by the way.
It's like this is supposed
to be a funny book,
they'll think that's
so depressing.
MELISSA POULOS: It
is really funny.
RAKESH SATYAL: We all felt bad.
It was the feel bad of the year.
MELISSA POULOS: One
last question from me,
and then I'll open it
up to the audience.
There's a lot of--
some of the subplots
in the book talk
about the Indian immigrant
community in this town.
And then there are some
who are sort of outsiders
to that, who come in.
And I think you, I
would think, growing up
kind of felt caught, kind
of between those two things.
And how did you, yourself,
in writing this, as well,
kind of reconcile that
idea of immigrant enclave,
community, what
your parents know,
and how they live
their life, versus
what became this very sort
of diverse, global lifestyle
that you built for yourself.
And maybe kind of how they
reacted to your evolution,
away from what they
knew into something.
RAKESH SATYAL: I mean, I often
say to people that I have--
I'm in the very
luxurious position
that nobody about
whom I care dearly,
or whom I think to care
dearly about me, ever
had a great issue
with my coming out.
That it a luxury.
I think, I'm not saying the
preponderance of people,
but I think a number of South
Asian people in particular
who come out don't necessarily
have that experience.
My parents are
incredibly supportive.
The funny thing is
that they're actually--
they had a love
marriage, which I
didn't realize
how anomalous that
was in our community
until much later actually.
I thought there must
be other families that
were in that same--
meaning, they didn't have
an arranged marriage, you know.
And so they are a
bit more-- they've
been progressive in a way.
My fraternal twin brother,
who's a marketing executive
at Heineken, and my
older brother, Rajiv,
is a pretty successful
stand-up comic.
So they've been very
encouraging of us.
And I often say that a
lot of Indian parents
will say do what we want
you to do and do it well.
And they said do what you
want to do, but do it well,
which is really helpful.
But one of the things I was
very carefully and intentionally
doing in the book was to
take these themes and tropes
that we think of
as being, quote,
unquote ethnic literature,
or quote, unquote,
Indian-American
literature, and think
about what I thought
was true and what
I thought should be
subverted to show
what I believed to be true.
And so I did think about
the community a great deal.
But what I didn't want to do--
I was saying this to my
brother the other day-- was
almost the difference
between saying
what people want
you to say, what's
the difference between
people who eat Indian food
and who eat American food.
And I was talking about what's
the difference between Indian
people who eat Chipotle
versus like Ponderosa,
or-- that didn't
make any sense--
why am I even saying Ponderosa.
I'm from Ohio.
But like you're having a
different conversation.
Like we're a few generations in.
Like it's not just that anymore.
It's like how are people living
their Americanized lives,
and to what actually
are they holding
on to from their previous
culture, more so than coming
at it the other way.
So I definitely felt
a responsibility
to depict that in a way
that I felt was accurate.
But I didn't want to
just retread territory
that I felt had been
tread before in fiction.
Because, especially in the
queer elements of the book,
I wanted to be true
to that narrative,
because you don't
see that as much.
And I wanted to kind of just
forge ahead and do that,
with the idea that
other people, especially
with the comedic elements, the
book may take that and think
about how they want to see
the world, either comedically,
or a bit more progressively.
MELISSA POULOS: Questions
from the audience.
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MELISSA POULOS: You
have to go to the mic.
We're recording.
Thanks, Henry.
RAKESH SATYAL: Oh, hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello, is this on?
So my question is actually
around the business
of book publishing.
And as someone who sees
both the editor or editor,
business side of
it, and then someone
who creates a novel, how much
did that inform your process?
Like I want to make
a successful book,
I want to make good book
that can turn into a movie.
How do you counsel
authors on that?
And how did you take
your own advice?
RAKESH SATYAL: Yeah,
what it's most helpful
for on the creative end is
that I'm not necessarily
taking those things
and saying, yeah,
like I'm going to make this
commercially successful,
or I'm going to make this
cinematic successful.
I'm definitely not doing
commercially successful,
because there's
so much gay stuff,
and it's like paced in
a very particular way.
And I'm like, that was not--
but it gives you a perspective
on what's happening,
what's happening in fiction,
what's happening industry wise,
how are people reacting
to other books that
purport to do this, or what are
other books that have come out
in the past few years, and
how are they structured,
and who went to
those books and why.
I really-- I do
tell people this.
And it seems like a cop out.
But if you let
yourself be dictated
by market concerns
like that, regardless
of your creative pursuit,
I just feel like it's
a lose-lose situation.
Because you're hemming in
whatever ideas you might have.
Also there's no originality
that comes into play there.
I think-- I tell my
authors a lot that
write the book you would want
to read, but more so, entertain
yourself.
Because you're sitting there
writing it all the time.
And if you're not entertained,
and if you're getting
frustrated--
I mean, there's frustration
in the writing process
to be sure--
but if it's not entertaining
you and keeping you engaged,
it's not going to
engage other people.
So what the publishing
process helps, in the sense--
going through the
production process,
for example, like once you
go through copy editing,
and you go through typesetting,
and cover considerations,
and all those things
that come into play--
I mean, I had the great luck
of having an amazing editor,
whom I really trusted.
I really trusted
her to do her job.
And I didn't want to be that
person who worked in publishing
telling her how to do her job.
But that demystified
that process for me,
because I think a lot of my
authors do get to that stage.
Like I wrote the book.
Thank god, now do
these 500 things
that you have to do after that.
So it helps in that respect.
But, certainly, you see--
you got a view of
the industry, and how
to engage people, and
get your work out there.
And especially have a
voice on social media,
and how you engage people
when you do events,
and how you do events,
all those things
are very helpful when
you're in publishing.
But I try to impart as much of
that as possible to the people
with whom I work, so they
can benefit from that.
AUDIENCE: You actually
started touching on this
in the end of that answer.
In terms of how you get
your work out there and have
a presence on social media,
can you talk a little bit
about some of the things you've
done to promote your work,
perhaps how you incorporated
your cabaret background,
or your singing,
just if there happens
to be anything like that.
But also just how you build
public presence and persona
as a writer.
RAKESH SATYAL: Well,
that's a great question.
There's a term that
people use a lot now,
which is being a good literary
citizen, the idea that if you
want to write, and if
you want to be part
of the world of
writing and publishing
is you have to
read a great deal,
and you have to support
the writers and the books
that you really love.
That is the wonderful
thing about social media,
is that it's connected
people in that way.
One writer who's
amazing, on Twitter,
and she's just a lovely
person, Celeste Ng,
who wrote this book,
"Everything I Never
Told You," which is an amazing
book, and her new book,
"Little Fires Everywhere,"
comes out this fall.
And Celeste is just such
a warm, wonderful person.
And she's so great
about vocalizing
her support of other
authors, and using
the platform she has
a successful author
to support people's writing.
I knew her only a little
bit through Twitter,
and she was very kind to give
me a quote for the book, which
was wonderful.
And it was that kind of
idea, being connected to her,
because we are fans of each
other's work, and writing,
and senses of humor.
And so it's great to be online.
When you read a book,
and you really enjoy it,
I think sometimes people
think, you know, I read it,
and I really enjoyed that.
Sometimes, you know,
send the author--
tweet the author, or
find the author's email,
or send a note to the
author's agent, or something,
because people really
love that, to hear
that something
connected with somebody,
that that's an invaluable
thing as a writer.
So I think that's
definitely one way,
is to kind of be in that world.
And I tell people
if you're a writer,
and you're trying to figure
out how to find an agent,
read the acknowledgements
of the books that you enjoy.
And they'll usually
thank their agents there.
And that gives you an idea
of who is working with whom,
and how that works.
And the cabaret thing, to
debase myself completely,
if you Google me, look
on YouTube, it's probably
the first thing that pops up,
I did a Hamilton themed book
trailer for this book, where I
sang the song "You'll be Back,"
in Hamilton, but I
made it by my book.
So if you find that, you'll find
me wearing a really ridiculous
outfit and singing that.
So I try to bring
that to bear as well.
But really, the thing is we've
learned in publishing too,
is that the idea of the old
school book tour reading
doesn't work as much.
Like people think I'll set an
event, and I'll do something,
and people will come.
And the truth is you
have to engage with it.
Like you have to go
places where you know
people, where you
can bring people.
And do something aside from
just a typical reading.
Even I, I'm a novelist,
I work in publishing,
my attention span after
five minutes has a tendency
to dissipate, and
I'm in that world.
So the more you can do
something where you do
something besides just reading.
If you sing, if you give a
special talk about a topic
that really means
something to you.
If you talk about other
things in your life
that are really important
that inform the process,
that has a way of opening
up the world of the book
to other people.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
for coming today.
My question is actually
related to the first question.
Also about the
business, because you've
been on both sides of
the aisle, so to speak.
With a lot of Indian and
South Asian stars and themes
coming into the forefront,
in terms of TV shows,
like "Mindy
Project," "Quantico,"
"Master of None,"
and documentaries
like, "Meet the Patels," have
you noticed that your work is
being optioned differently,
or people are treating it
differently now than
your first book, say?
RAKESH SATYAL: That's
a really good question,
if that kind of sea change
has allowed that to happen.
What I appreciate about a
great number of the things
that you mentioned is that a lot
of them actually are comedic.
Because to go back to my earlier
point about some of the themes
I was exploring
when I was writing
the book is that from my
kind of life research, when
I was thinking about the
category, what I found
is that what I saw as the
prevailing narrative was
that most immigrant
literature, and especially
South Asian literature,
focus on a grief narrative,
that there be something really
sad happening in the book.
And that regardless of
any moments of levity
that happened in the
book, that default sadness
is the most viable emotion.
And what I did,
very consciously,
as you can see with the
laugh out loud funny section
that I read at the
beginning, is that is
that I was taking
actually that idea
and then taking
it somewhere else.
And so what I do
appreciate is this idea--
I think most people's lives,
even when there's trauma,
your default state is not
necessarily the trauma.
It's the mundane things in
life, and the little things
that happen to you over the
course of the day that actually
have comedy in them,
or confusion in them,
or self-reflection in them, in
a different way besides simply
sadness, or effacing yourself.
So what I appreciate about
all the things you mentioned,
is that people do
have a tendency
to come to and
understand that, oh, I
see what you're doing here.
It's not just falling into
this rote emotional state,
but in fact, there's
a wider world
emotionally than what we
typically give people.
And I hope that
continues to happen.
I am very heartened to see--
there was that picture.
I'm so geeked out.
There was that picture
from the Met Ball,
where it was Riz Ahmed, Hussein
Bin Haj, Azus Ansari and Mindy
Kaling, all in the
same photo, just
like baller at the Met Ball.
And I was like that's so
great, that's how it should be.
It should be people representing
different backgrounds
and having that different
cultural conversation.
So I really--
I do think people
are doing that now.
And that it's by building
it over time that you see
it come to fruition that way.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rakesh,
thanks for coming.
I had a question about
the industry overall.
And again, as people
have asked, you
have this unique
position of being
across the various
aspects of the industry,
a writer, publisher.
Actually, pre-question is, is
that common across writers,
to be--
RAKESH SATYAL: There are
people, like you usually
know who they are.
They're like spread out
through the industry.
But there are a few of us, yeah.
There are a few of us.
And
AUDIENCE: The second
question is what
do you think the future of
the industry looks like?
And will publishers
get disintermediated?
And how does that affect
the quality of the book?
And will that, for
example, proliferate
the emergence of more writers?
RAKESH SATYAL: Thank you for
the most Google question of all.
Everybody knows that publishing
in general, across spectra,
regardless of what medium
you're in within that industry,
is always going to be
volatile in some way.
So that is a kind of a priori
fact of being in the industry.
I do think we are in a
particularly exciting time.
Because I will say, like
I just did a two week book
tour, where I went and did
like eight or nine events.
And most of those events
were in indie bookstores.
And we hear about this in
the industry, the resurgence
of the indie bookstore.
And it's true.
I mean, like you
see it happening.
You see it in New York.
There's Greenlight
in Fort Greene.
There's Word bookstore
in Greenpoint.
It's there.
They have another location they
opened in Jersey City, which
is amazing.
There's Books are Magic,
Emma Straub's new store.
There's the second Greenlight
location in Lefferts Gardens.
So it's-- so those stores are
becoming-- what they did is,
they really saw the moment
to have a cultural center
at the bookstore.
Like that was what it was
like when I think a lot of us
were growing up, was you
went to the bookstore.
And then there was this
moment where places closed,
and chains closed, and
Borders closed, and you really
worried about it.
And now, people are kind of
taking into their own hands
and saying, we can
build a community here.
And to my earlier point, a
lot of the reasons why that--
one of the reasons
why that works
is because the programming
has become central to them.
We'll get authors to come
here and speak about things,
and we'll do events here,
and we'll do kids events,
and we'll bring in people
of different backgrounds
to actually be on site and talk
about books in a different way.
And that has made that
sector of publishing
all the more appealing to
people and all the more
vital to everything.
So that's very exciting.
And then what we
saw is this idea
that a few years
ago this great fear
that everything
would turn digital
and that ebooks would
just eclipse everything.
And now we've seen it even
out in a way, where people do
care about the physical book.
I mean, I certainly do.
And I love to--
I'm like, hold this
actual book in your hands.
Like it looks beautiful.
So people are
becoming-- publishers
are becoming savvy about
how to play with format,
and packaging, and
engaging people visually
in a certain way
that's different.
I should say where I work,
Atria Books, our publisher,
Judith Curry, is a complete
visionary, where the imprint
itself is celebrating its
50th year, and she began it.
And her kind of porousness in
terms of how she thinks about
how we package books, and
how we get them to market,
and how we engage digitally with
different formats, and apps,
it's so forward thinking
that it gives me
great hope for what
people are going
to be able to going forward.
So I think it just takes--
I would love to
see inroads between
nontraditional
publishing thinking
and traditional
to bring them all together.
And I think that's only going
to help people over time.
So I know that seems very
kind of like overly optimistic
in a way, but I
do think you have
to lead creatively in that way.
Like the thing with the books
is in an editorial meeting, when
we're sitting there, we have
to feel really passionately
editorially about something.
And the content and
the creative really
has to be there so that other
people can understand that.
I often said the editor's
job traffics in trickle
down enthusiasm, because
you are a liaison
among all the divisions
of the publishing company.
As an editor, I'm talking to
sales, publicity, marketing,
and then the eventual reader.
So your enthusiasm
has to be so great,
that as you give it to
other people, they take it
and run with it.
So if the editors are really
looking for that content
and seeing great creative work
being done, and champion it,
then that will always be
a constant in publishing.
MELISSA POULOS: More questions?
AUDIENCE: So I guess
I wanted to ask you
because you are both an
editor and a writer, what
was your editor's, I
guess, biggest comment,
and I'm sure he or she had
many, but what was their biggest
overall feedback for you?
And was there anything
that you disagreed with?
RAKESH SATYAL: Oh, no,
there was no editing.
It was perfect.
My editor, Anna
deVries, is a genius.
And the lesson I really
learned from her, that I've
been trouble with with
a lot of my writers,
is a lot of the times
when you write something,
even when you've revised
it and revised it,
you know something
isn't working,
but you just don't want to
admit it because it's more work.
Here comes laziness again.
You could feel
like, I don't want
to do that, I have this creative
vision and I will stand by it.
So the book is told in very
alternating narratives.
And it's paced very consciously,
almost like it's a sitcom.
It's cutting among
the various narratives
over the course of the book.
And originally when
I did the book,
there's three main
narratives, that I
mentioned at the beginning.
It was a really long
chunk about the first one,
and a really long chunk
about the second one,
and a really chunk
about the third.
And then, a third of the
way through the book, they
were braided together.
And then things started
happening that way.
And she just kind
of said to me, she
was like you realize that
it should be like that
from the beginning, right?
And I knew that.
I completely knew that.
It just took more editing
and I was just so--
I'd worked so long on it.
And I just was like, no,
this is like avant garde,
like you're just pulled
into the worlds separately,
and then you're amazed
when it comes together.
And she was like, really?
So that was like the most
helpful note in a way.
There wasn't much-- I really
don't think there was anything
we really disagreed about.
There was one section,
of a few pages, where
I felt an obligation to
keep that section in,
because it was about one
of the younger characters,
and it was about a
moment in his life
where he's sort
of feeling adrift.
And it really drives
home the point
about just how romantically
clueless he is.
And that was a short
section I kept in.
But as soon as I told her
that I'd like to keep that in,
she was like I completely
get why you're doing that.
So it's a very--
you have to trust your
editor a great deal.
And I really trusted her.
And if-- and she was
very mindful of what
I was trying to do creatively,
the fact that there were
certain themes,
especially queer themes,
I was not going to budge
on, and she would not
wanted to have budged on.
Wow, there's a conjugation.
So like it was very
beneficial to work with her
and have that
connection with her.
MELISSA POULOS: One last
question, I think we have time.
AUDIENCE: It's been
eight years since you
wrote your first book.
Now when I look back
at things I wrote
years ago, I always
read them and think,
am I even the same person?
So I'm wondering what has
changed about your writing
style?
If you read your
first book recently,
do you look at it like,
whoa, like my writing style
has changed a lot?
And if so, what has changed?
RAKESH SATYAL: I think
about that a lot.
And then I stopped
thinking about it,
because it drives me insane.
I think what it is--
what I've heard from a
lot of people, who've
read the book, which
I greatly appreciate,
there's great warmth in it.
And the way my--
I kind of subconsciously
thought about it this way--
but the way my
editor describes is
there's great compassion
for the characters.
And that and that was incredibly
key to me as I was writing.
And I wanted there to be
that level of empathy.
But I think that's the way I
will always approach writing.
And the thing I keep telling
people is the lesson I really
learn with this book,
and is evidenced
in the first book
from a long time ago,
is that my writing is really
often about who is happening,
not what is happening.
Because I find that those--
in the book, for example,
I was talking about some
of those mundane things
that happen in life.
In the book, there's
a certain rhythm
where a character will be
doing something-- like this
happens many times in the book.
A certain character will be
doing something very mundane,
like driving somewhere, or
cooking something, or eating
something.
And then there's almost a
disposition at the end of it
where it's punctuated by
the interior monologue that
was happening to that character
while that scene was happening.
And to me, and to your point
earlier, one of the things
I was looking at, a key theme in
the book was, if you're lonely,
and you feel your
loneliness palpably,
that in fact, loneliness
can be incredibly construct.
That in a way, when you're
alone with your thoughts, that's
when you do some of your
most productive thinking,
and your most productive
self-reflection
to figure out what you
actually value in the world,
and what you think you
might change about yourself,
or examine about yourself.
So I think that's
something I've noticed,
is that I feel a bit more
validated, and enthused,
and verified in a way
to sort of do that.
Like my writing has a
certain warmth to it,
and a certain compassion,
and humor to it.
And I'm leading with that.
That's not incidental
to what I'm doing.
But it's actually
quite central to what
my goals are as a writer.
MELISSA POULOS: Well, thank
you so much for being here.
RAKESH SATYAL: Thank you
very much, everybody,
for being here.
MELISSA POULOS: We have
books for sale at the back.
And we're wishing you
the best for tonight.
Rakesh is actually going to be
on Late Night with Seth Meyers
this evening.
So tune in.
Follow him, check out the book.
And I wanted to
close with something
that I thought was so
inspiring that you shared
on Twitter a couple weeks ago,
when we were actually together
that weekend at our
college reunion.
And you said grew up in Ohio,
somehow got into Princeton.
Here for my 15th
reunion with my hubby
and read from my second book.
Dream big my LGBTQ children.
Like so amazing.
So, thank you so
much for being here.
I really appreciate it.
RAKESH SATYAL:
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]